[Musique]
j'ai encore des
visuels de départ
alors je ne
sais toujours pas pourquoi mais ceux-ci
et je n'oublierai jamais de voir ces
chevaux
et d'être entouré d'un anneau de feu
et je l'ai juste perdu
et c'est là que j'aime ma force juste
a disparu
et je dois encore en parler en
thérapie parce que ça me hante ça me
hante
[Musique]
déménager toute une famille
est un défi
alors quand les incendies sont arrivés et que nous avons
tout perdu
j'ai tout de suite dit à ryan nous quittons la
californie nous  Je ne peux plus rester ici
[Musique]
L'une des premières choses que nous avons faites lorsque nous avons
déménagé ici, c'est que nous venons d'avoir un thérapeute
et je n'ai jamais réalisé le traumatisme qui
existe toujours en moi à cause de ce SSPT
et comment il se déclenche et donc juste
le  le processus émouvant de traverser la ville
euh au cours des deux derniers jours a juste
déclenché les choses et être honnête avec il y
a eu une cascade de larmes sans vraiment
comprendre pourquoi et se sentir si brisé
à l'intérieur
[Musique]
vous